it's time now for CBS morning's deals
where we share some items that might
help make your day a little easier all
at exclusive low discounts and to start
shopping now scan the QR code on your
screen or you can visit
cdsdeals.com lifestyle host Gail bass
joins us right now so let's get this
thing started oh yeah let's get this
started I got this I want to warm things
up because it's a cold morning is that
from America oh yeah this is for you
this is the calming heat now I'm going
to put that on do you feel the heat
already there you go and I'm just going
to press that little button right there
I feel the heat whoa and it vibrates too
oh you surprised me with that
it's weighted it's heated and it
vibrates if you have tension in your
neck if you've been like bending over
your computer and you're typing like
this this is perfect or if you have
teenagers because apparently they cause
stress in your life sometimes of course
I got those oh yeah Tony has a stand-up
desk so he's constantly looking down at
his computer I think he'll like this oh
yeah this would be a very nice gift for
him but I say do it for yourself here's
the CBS deals on this
23.99 this is something you want to get
now because this is the kind of thing
that people are going to like oh that's
a deal all right all right so what about
these knots I really love these knives
by caloric uh calorics excuse me these
things are fantastic they're so well
balanced they're beautiful and they're
made of carbon steel these are the
things that you want to have in your
kitchen when you like to cook check out
they are look at that oh I could barely
feel the fact that I'm slicing through a
carrot Ikea Tony in the background
because he likes to cook and so do I I
love about Gail though I'm the Gale that
likes to cook and I love these these are
a perfect gift for somebody who doesn't
have really good knives or let's say you
need a Hostess gift of this
thanksgiving's coming up next week this
is a wonderful gift for 38 dollars for
all three yeah for all three think about
it when you see those knife blocks
you're spending hundreds of dollars this
is under forty dollars for these three
wonderful carbon steel knives that means
you don't have to sharpen them as
frequently ah I like that hey Merry
Christmas just egg surprise when I send
them to you 38 that's how much you're
worth and that's a wonderful what is
this that looks like a toy car this is
not a toy car but hey if you like toy
cars or putting stuff together this is
for you this is the Kelvin 23. I love it
because not only is it a flashlight
right there okay it flashes right there
it is also a multi-tool there's a
leveler on top there is a level on top
so if you're wanting to balance pictures
or you're in the store buying a picture
and you want to see how long it is
there's a tape measure but wait there's
more right here flip that open and
you've got a screwdriver and watch that
it comes with 16 bits so you know it's
gonna get good when somebody says but
wait oh yeah flat heads and the fact
that it's a hammer I love that you can
you can use that this is truly a
multi-tool wow wow and it's small you
can keep it anywhere yes you can keep it
anywhere you can keep it in your purse
you can keep it in your pocket if you
have big pockets on those overalls where
you don't have to have multiple tools
that's why it's called a multitude talk
to me though what's the price on that
the price on this is 29.99
yeah you go to cbsdeals.com now to get
these because you don't want them to get
bought out by everybody else and this is
a great price for a limited time and
with the holiday season here perfect
gifts yeah this is a perfect gift for a
college student the handyman who fixes
everything for women who are handy women
I fix stuff I I use this when I go out
mountain biking and maybe your
derailleur has a little issue this is
something that you want to use on so
many different things keep it in your
car use it in your RV take it on the
boat it's going to be useful wherever
you go
appreciate you all right of course we
partner with all of these companies to
get the deals you can buy anything that
you saw today or other items scan the QR
code on your screen right now or just
head over to cbsdeals.com to start
shopping it's holiday season go ahead